hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com
so in this video i would like to go with
you through yesterday's price action on
amc we had the second quarter earnings
announcement that arrived just after
market so we have some very interesting
things
here to analyze and i also want to show
you some cool options strategies that
you can use if you want
to maximize your profits during the
squeeze so let's get into it
[Music]
all right so the first thing let me
remind you of the big picture guys
so we had a first leg up here
in jan then correction then third wave
which was the second leg up
in may now we are correcting so you know
we can see for example this correction
lasts from jan so roughly three months
if we correct three months again it
brings us to the third of september
so i don't know just looking at this the
price action like to repeat the past
so maybe we're gonna have a move in
september maybe even before
so i'm gonna zoom in here but first one
more thing i want to show you guys here
once again
it's just like all right i just do this
and this is how i find my tag at 135 so
i believe we're gonna go there
and i'm gonna try here to show you when
okay so it really depends actually when
we break this trend line so let me zoom
in here a little bit
okay so we're having here this trendline
once again we saw some picked outs
before so
this is the best signal i could use here
is a breakout and we had some pass
breakout that actually were fakeouts
so that's why i'm going to show you here
some cool options strategies
that you know you cannot lose money i
mean you can only you
lose your premium so i think that pretty
cool here to use
and i would use this option strategies
once we have the breakouts so you know
to optimize my entry level and so here
what we can see let me even zoom in a
little bit more
bam bam bam all right so what is very
interesting here is that we have this
short term breakout all right i
updated you guys on my discord like
every day by the way this is for free
i keep amc and gme recap for free i'm
gonna keep it like this
because it's interesting for a lot of
you to have this information so i want
to keep sharing it with you
and i was saying that here what we want
to see is a breakout of the 34 level
which we had
and then after market there were the
earnings uh less negative than expected
which is good news
of course amc is not following
fundamentals but this kind of news they
are catalyzer for
all the investors to jump in the market
together and it's
good news all right so we still are
happy to hear this kind of good
announcements
and so here we have this breakout so
technically this is looking very good
we had already this bullish regular
divergence that is here that was showing
that the market is out of steam
here it was a big battle lost by the
bears guys right this was a
beautiful bear trap or terrible bedrock
call it the way you want but it was a
bear trap
and the bears remember it and so this is
the reason why those kind of divergence
they're
gonna impact the price roughly during
the period between the lows
so here it's like july and august so one
month and a half
so everything that happened here is
gonna impact the market for this
time roughly bam okay so until the 20th
of august
and this combined with the breakout is
looking good so here
it looks like we are going to the major
resistance
area which is this trend line guys all
right
so i'm pretty sure that i'm not the only
one using this
so this area and i think that here is
going to be maybe the signal that the
next move up is starting so let's try to
see
when this could happen because this is i
know what you guys are interested in
so very honestly i don't know but we can
try to you know just to see visually
what could happen what would make sense
i don't know maybe something like this
would make sense so if you break out
right now
you know it can even go faster so i
don't know i think that september is a
bit short
but it could happen if we break out
right away
this week above 40 so 40 is the level to
watch
right now if we break out above 40 this
week
we're probably gonna have a small retest
after that and then go higher
so i would rather go for gen 21
options like maturities if i have to set
up some strategies
but september is going to be much
cheaper so it's interesting maybe to
look at it too
so once again what we want to see is a
breakout here and
as long as we don't have this breakout i
cannot eliminate uh for now the
bearish case that is going to 24 right
so it would be like something like this
and then we bounce back so then we would
take longer we would have to break out
here and for now as long as we are below
this blue trend line so below 40 roughly
today
this is still on the table unfortunately
so i would
still be careful here we don't have the
strong you know medium term bullish
signal for now even if it's looking
uh quite good and i just wanted to point
out the fact that in this correction
we have a one-to-one relation between a
wave and c wave which is once again
following here
the elliot wave and the fib ratio rules
so here wxy or abc you need
usually have a one-to-one relation
between those two
legs those ratios when they are
respected it's suggesting that the
counting is correct
so this is you know just confirming that
this correction might be over and guys
so now i want to show you some cool
option strategies that you can make if
you want to enjoy as much as possible
this fifth wave so let's have a look at
it the question is that
you often asking me on my discord is
like which maturity would you choose and
which strike
or strategy would you try to make
so first for the maturity i like to
trade the liquid once
it's september or june 22 but the
scenario we are playing
is not going to happen i mean jan 22 i
mean maybe
but we are playing here the scenario
that we have this fifth wave
coming soon all right so for this reason
i would go to the september maturity
that is going to be much cheaper you can
see that for example
i like to buy some strikes that are
located at the next resistance level so
that if you go above this resistance
level
then it becomes support and then the you
are very likely to finish in the money
so you can see that for example the
difference in premium between a 40
strike call on the september maturity
which is 700
and a gen 22 is you know basically
hundred percent
difference so you need to pay twice as
much for
gen 22 so for this reason i would prefer
to go to september
all right and if you want to unwind it
the i mean it's going to be as well
easier for september
because the gen 22 you need to wait very
long so then you need to unwind it
and we are playing the scenario where
we're gonna actually go higher in
september so we're gonna be happy to be
long a call here so one more thing i
want to show you
is you know some parameter that we can
compute that is called the lstc team
okay so spot performance
all right so for example let's compare
for example if you were to do i don't
know
100 strikes all right so the performance
is equal to
so up blue cap off this level
that we're gonna try to find here uh
g so seven and exact match
all right bam uh divided by the premium
all right
okay so this is the performance that you
make
compared to initial investments so you
can see that if we go for 40 strike code
for the september maturity
we make plus 600 roughly we go from 700
invested to around 6 thousand
so now let's see if we go for example
for another strike because i know that
you guys like to go from some higher
strikes
and let's see what is the difference so
here
oh we have a better performance so we
pay only 300 so we make less money but
we invest less as well
so basically compared to initial
investment you have a better performance
so this is the first thing i wanted to
show you the higher
strike you you choose the more
performance you're gonna have compared
to initial investment this is what we
call elasticity
but you're gonna start to generate
profits at a higher level
so this is the risk so basically you
have more leverage
all right compared to initial investment
but the probability that you finish in
the money is of course
lower in this situation i would not go
for too high strike all right
because my guess is that september we
would be in the move up
but i don't know if we're gonna reach 70
or not so
if we finish at 60 we still want to make
some money so for this reason
i would go for you know if i need to
choose a naked call i would go for the
4d strike call
here and the volatility is lower you can
see that here i
i have a volatility of 177 percent
here 187 percent and this is impacting
so this is the black shop's formula that
is using the volatility so for example
if the variety goes to 150
the price goes from 7.73 to 11 all right
so you can see that here we have a
big sensitivity to volatility and for
this reason you don't want to buy
those volatility that are too expensive
you actually want to be selling those
all right
when i was working you know as an option
trader when i was seeing a volatility
higher than hundred i was like
let's sell this so this is what
protrader is actually doing we don't buy
those high volatility we sell them so
how can we here
take some upside performance and sell
the high volatility
um question and i have an answer so you
buy the 40 because once again we want to
start making money early
but you're gonna sell for example the
100 right so this is what we call a cold
spread
and now i'm taking full advantage of
this high volatility that i have here
compared to the one i'm buying i'm
buying the 177 i'm selling 215
and you can see that once again there is
a very high impact imagine this one was
at 215 as well
i would not pay 550 i would pay 717
so you can see that the in volatility
has a very strong impact on the price
even on those short-term maturity
options
and this is the type of things that you
know i want to show you guys all right
because
this is things that you know when you
work as a pro trader that
you know people show you that you know
because like you work in this
environment
and that's why i want to you know share
all this knowledge with you guys that's
why i created this channel
that's why i created my discord and this
is the type of strategies that i will
try to show you
as much as i can especially after
september when we're gonna start live
training
with another trader that is now in the
project and it's going to be very
exciting to do all of these things
so once again if you are not there yet
guys just click on the link in the
description of this video
and you can enjoy one more week guys
with 25 percent off
then i have no choice i would put my
prices higher because i don't want too
many people there so i can answer all of
your questions
and thank you so much guys for asking me
all these questions by the way
it's exactly what i want there to happen
is that you know we have a lot of
interactions a lot of questions i would
of course start to make some you know
kind of
classes for beginners to try to teach
you guys you know the basics because
some of you are very advanced
some of you are less advanced you know
so
this is the project i'm having and this
is the type of things that i will try to
share with you
so here let me conclude what i would do
i would go on the september maturity
because it's cheaper and because this is
the move we are playing
i would buy for this tranquil because i
think that
we might be ongoing in the move up so i
don't want to buy a strike too high
even if i have more leverage and you
know i have a better elasticity with a
higher strike
i prefer to buy a 40 strike call and
selling the 101 to enjoy this difference
of volatility and once again by doing
that i
maximize guys the performance compared
to my initial investment
plus 1 000 in this situation all right
so this is for me the best trade that we
can make and
in terms of unwind strategy here we keep
it until maturity that's why we choose a
short maturity
and we just hope that it's going to
finish as
high as possible in september right
there is nothing to do
you just go for that and you uh hope
that this finishes in the money
so this is what i would personally do so
i hope you guys enjoyed this video i
hope i managed to explain
how to take advantage of the volatility
market how to choose your maturity how
to choose
strike you know by uh reminding you
where is the
next resistance level uh stuff like this
so if you did enjoy this video please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys